THUS FAR.
1ST, TRUMP TAKES ON THE ELITE IN
DAVOS AND IS THE FOCUS OF
GATHER ONCE A YEAR IN A TOWN AND
THE SWISS HELPS TO DISCUSS
POLITICAL, ECONOMIC AND
HUMANITARIAN CHANGES FACING THE
WORLD.
AS A BUSINESSMAN, TRUMP NEVER
MADE THE GUEST LIST AND IS THE
1ST PRESIDENT TO GO TO DAVOS
SINCE BILL CLINTON WHO ONLY
ATTENDED HIS LAST YEAR IN OFFICE
AND IS A CONFERENCE AWARE YOUR
NET WORTH IS DESCRIBED WITH
TRUMPS AND NOT MS.
>>> WORLD LEADERS FROM
ADVANCE OF TRUMP'S APPEARANCE AT
STREET JOURNAL GETTY.
>> FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK
>> THAT IS A BAD POSTER.
EXPECTATIONS AND IS SURPRISING
THE WORLD CRASHING THEIR SWANKY
PARTY AND THE WORLD LEADERS
CONTINUE TO HIT HIS POLICIES ON
TRADE, THEY ARE TAKING NOTICE.
ILIAD SCRAMBLE TO TAKE SELFIES
WITH HIM AND COULD NOT STOP
TALKING ABOUT HIM ELBOWING
PEOPLE OUT OF THE WAY ON THE
STAIRWAY OR ESCALATOR TO GET
CLOSE AND THERE WAS SUBSTANCE
HEAR WHAT HE HAD TO SAY IN
SITTING NEXT TO THE ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER, TRYING LAURA:DOT
TRUMP THREATENED TO HOLD EIGHT A
MUST THEY RETURNED TO THE PEACE
AND THEN, THIS IS IMPORTANT,
CHALLENGED HIM.
>> ISRAEL SAYS THEY WANT TO MAKE
PEACE, THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
WANT TO MAKE PEACE ALSO OR WE
WILL HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
AND TOOK IT OFF THE TABLE.
YOU WILL WIN A POINT AND GIVE UP
POINTS LATER IN THE NEGOTIATION
IF IT EVER TAKES PLACE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL EVER
THINK WE TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> THEY HAVE A GUTSY NEGOTIATOR
AND SEE IT ALL PLAY OUT AND IN
THE PRESIDENT SAT DOWN WITH THE
UK PRIME MINISTER MEI HUA STILL
SUFFERING FROM THE PROPOSED
BREXIT BLUES AND HAS A VERY
>> THE PRIME MINISTER AND MYSELF
HAVE HAD A REALLY GREAT RELATION
HAVE HAD A REALLY GREAT RELATIOH
HAVE HAD A REALLY GREAT RELATIOP
.
SOME PEOPLE, THOUGH,
NECESSARILY, BELIEVE THAT
>> AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
MEETING, IT WAS ANNOUNCED THE
WITHIN THE YEAR.
IT WILL BE A WORKING TRIP, WE
>>> CONTRARY TO ALL THAT
HYPERBOLE COMING FROM WE ARE THE
WORLD TYPES, TRUMP WILL NOT STOP
INTO THE U.S. AND HAVE A LOT OF
NEWS LATER IN THE SHOW ABOUT
WHAT WILL BE SPECIFICALLY
OFFERED AND THE PRESIDENT'S DEAL
ON IMMIGRATION.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL DO IS
PURSUE CHANGES IN POLICIES DETRM
PURSUE CHANGES IN POLICIES DETRN
PURSUE CHANGES IN POLICIES DETRA
PURSUE CHANGES IN POLICIES DETRL
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
OF THAT MEANS AMERICA WILL NO
LONGER TOLERATE BEING TAKEN ADVA
LONGER TOLERATE BEING TAKEN ADVT
LONGER TOLERATE BEING TAKEN ADVG
LONGER TOLERATE BEING TAKEN ADVE
HABITS AND INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
STOLEN BY RIVALS.
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
WHETHER YOU ARE AND HOW IT LIKE
SOUTH KOREA OR AN ADVERSARY LIKE
CHINA, AND WERE PRESIDENT HAS
PUT YOU ON NOTICE THAT THE OLD
DAYS OF PRACTICING GLOBALIZATION
ON THE BACKS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE ALSO OVER.
>> MY ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING
POWER BACK FROM GLOBAL
BUREAUCRATS AND RETURNING THAT
POWER BACK TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND SEE IT ALL THE TIME.
YOU SEE IT ECONOMICALLY, YOU SEE
WE DO NOT SEEING A GLOBAL AMP
AMP FROM.
HE HAS NOT PRESIDENT OF THE
WORLD, HE IS PRESIDENT OF THE
U.S.
SOME OF THESE WORLD LEADERS
CONTINUE TO DERIDE HIS POLICIES
AND TRIED HIM FROM THE
S IDELINES, THEY ARE TAKING NOTI
S IDELINES, THEY ARE TAKING NOTE
AND IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY, IT IS
HARD -- REFUGEES AND IMMIGRATION
IS TRANSFORMING THE WAY OTHER LE
IS TRANSFORMING THE WAY OTHER LD
IS TRANSFORMING THE WAY OTHER LR
IS TRANSFORMING THE WAY OTHER LS
THINK ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
THIS IS THE GERMAN CHANCELLOR
FROM TODAY.
>> EVEN FOREIGN-POLICY HAS NOT
BEEN ALL THAT -- IN THE PAST AND
NEED TO TAKE MORE RESPONSIBILITY
NEED TO TAKE MORE RESPONSIBILIT.
WE NEED TO TAKE OUR DESTINY INTO
OUR OWN HANDS.
>> LAURA:WE AGREE TAKE YOUR
DESTINY INTO YOUR OWN HANDS AND
IS CALLED SOVEREIGNTY AND WHAT
WE ARE ALL ABOUT, INDEPENDENT
FREE NATIONS WITH YOU NEED
IDENTITIES STANDING UP FOR THEIR
OWN INTERESTS AND WORKING WITH
OTHERS AND THAT IS WHAT TRUMP IS
ABOUT AND DOING HERE.
WE ARE TAKING OUR OWN DESTINY
INTO OUR OWN HANDS AND ARE NOT
FOR US.
AFTER SEEING TRUMP'S LEADERSHIP
ON BORDER ENFORCEMENT AND
IMMIGRATION, MS. MERKLE MIGHT BE
SEEING THE SAME WAY.
MISS OUT ON THIS AND NOT THINK
ABOUT THIS?
WE ARE SAFE AND SECURE AND NOW
WORKING ON AN ENTRY AND EXIT
SYSTEM.
>> LAURA:NO WONDER.
IN GERMANY IN 2016 THE CRIME
RATE AMONG REFUGEES SKYROCKETED
MORE THAN 50%.
ACCORDING TO THE TELEGRAPH,
MIGRANTS COMMITTED WITH A
175,000 SUSPECTED CRIMES IN
GERMANY.
SUDDENLY, PRESIDENT TRUMP LAW
SCENTED?
DOGMA AS THE FRENCH PRESIDENT
TODAY OR BRISTLE IF HIS DECISION
TO RENEGOTIATE NAFTA OR STAND UP
TO CHEATING WITH AN ELECTION
WILL PROPERTY BY CHINA AND OTHER
NATIONS.
HE IS, UNDOUBTEDLY, SHAKING OF
THE WORLD ORDER AND RESHAPING
THE GLOBAL DEBATE IN A VERY
POSITIVE WAY.
IT MIGHT NOT MAKE HIM ANY
FRIENDS AT DAVOS, TRUMP'S
AMERICA 1ST POSITION IS REVISING